you quote president dwight d eisenhower
in your book
quote plans are useless but planning is
essential
and you provide a thought experiment
called entropy goggles
can you describe this thought experiment
happily i do this almost every day
somewhere when i'm sitting in a given
room i will
uh well a quick could comment about that
quote actually for all the nasa planning
meetings for the twin study and other
missions that was often the quote that
goes put up on the wall before we'd sit
down for the day to plan the mission it
was that quote which is useless
which i thought was hilarious for a
official nasa meeting but it was because
you need to have a plan but you have to
know that plan might change and so i
think uh that's just a quick the context
for that quite craig kundra who's a
leader at nasa's headquarters now i
would always put that first light up and
i'm like hmm this meeting's either going
to go really well or really bad i don't
know what's about to happen but but it's
a inspiring quote because it's very true
in any case the entry p goggles is a
thought experiment i detail in in my
book which is
if you just sit in a room any room
wherever you are and and imagine what it
will look like in 10 years 100 years 500
years or even thousands of years
it is a wonderfully
terrifying and exciting exercise again
it's definitely both because he realized
the transience of everything that you
think of what might survive almost
everything that you're looking at will
probably not be there in hundreds of
years uh it will be you know it barely
degraded or it might be changed altered
completely different moved
it is
just in its that trait though of humans
to just sit there and project into the
future it's easily you know really
seamlessly with whatever you're doing
and previously
is is powerful because it shows the you
know what can change and what should
change in some cases but also that
you know left to you know its own
devices the universe would entropy would
come take over and really things would
decay things would be destroyed but the
only thing really preventing i think
some of the entropy is is with humans
these sort of sentient creatures that
are aware of extinction like ourselves
is really one of the only forces in the
universe that's counteracting the second
law of thermodynamics this entropy
that's always increasing
technically we're actually still
increasing it because we emit heat and
we never have perfect capture of all of
energy but we're the only things really
actively and consciously
resisting it really you could say life
in general does this like ants do this
when they build their big homes they're
rearranging the universe to make a nice
place for themselves and they're you
know counteracting entropy but we could
actually do it in a way that would be at
a large scale and for long term
so the entropy goggles is just a way to
realize
how transient everything is and just
imagine
everything that will decay or change in
the room around you so if anyone
listening if they're listening on a
train or they're driving in their car
wherever someone is listening right now
uh looking around everything can and
will change and so you that but then at
first it's terrifying to see that um oh
my gosh everything will decay and go
away
but then
i think it's actually liberating i think
wait i can affect this chain i can
prevent it or i can affect it or i can
improve the change that may occur
all by itself say naturally um and so i
think it is but is it that awareness
again of like you know the frailty of
life the ever uh insistence an increase
in entropy
that you can address though and actually
i say the same thing to first-year
medical students i teach them genetics i
say i point early in the course i say
here's all these charts of how the human
body decays over time it just and i call
it the inexorable march towards
molecular oblivion which the students
often find they kind of laugh at ah
because on all the charts they're 22
years old but
older people do not laugh as much of the
thought of molecular oblivion but we're
all marching towards it to a large
degree so this is both
a great thought experiment for the
environment around you so just looking
at all the objects around you
that they will
dissipate it will disappear with time
but then it's also
the thing you mentioned which is how can
i affect
any of the world
like uh you're one little creature
and
it's like uh your life is kind of
you get dropped into this ocean and you
make a little splash
and how do i make it so the splash lasts
for
a little bit longer because it
ultimately
will uh i mean i suppose the wave will
continue indefinitely but it'd be such a
small impact it's almost undetectable
and so how do i have that impact at all
on so many levels i get to experience
this
as a human like um
i recently had had my
cold storage uh hacked
uh to where it was locked essentially it
wasn't hacked it was locked and so you
get to lose all your data so for example
if you lose all your data if you lose
all your online presence your social
media your emails
if you
like think of all the things you could
lose in a fire there's been a lot of
fires in the united states if you lose
your home yeah
and it makes you realize wait a minute
this is exactly a nice simulation
of what will happen anyway
eventually
and that eventually comes pretty quickly
and so you it allows you to focus on
you know how can i actually affect
so what matters what lasts
and what brings me joy i suppose that
the ultimate answer is nothing lasts you
have to focus on the things in the
moment
that bring you joy and that have a
positive impact on those around you that
focusing on something that's long
lasting is perhaps
i don't know it's it's complicated right
because like
well it used to be foolhardy to say i
want to think legacy is often what
people think of as they approach the end
of their life what is my legacy what
have i done even younger in life but
it used to be really foolhardy to say i
could affect something that would learn
people would build the building
architecture i put my name on this
building and there i have some sense of
immortality
but that's a it's a fleeting dream it's
not you can't uh
reach immortality uh and if you could it
would be resource
you know taxing on everyone else if you
really really were
but i think it's it's okay
i mean the books for the next 500 years
but i presume i'll be dead for the vast
majority of that time and i i but that
is that is actually the liberating state
of mortality is you know that you don't
have forever so it means what can you do
that is the most impactful but you can
build things that you said i want to
pass this on to the next generation
again the most obvious thing we do with
this is if people have kids but you they
don't think of this as a as an
intergenerational responsibility i think
of as well i was at the bar one night
and i met this hot girl and then things
happened or sometimes it's more planned
than that but the
the
there's no overarching sense of weight i
could have something that three or four
generations from now well that someone
will receive this gift that was planned
for them long before they were born or
gestating
and i think we have that capacity and
that that can be a version of legacy but
it's even okay if if no one knows
exactly who started it but that the
benefit was was wrought by people
you know again hundreds or even
thousands of years after you got it
started so i think this
is again it's something that is um
only really people that are economically
secure can even begin to do this or you
can say you know think of maslow's
hierarchy of needs where you need to
satisfy your physical needs all your
structural needs and have shelter
and so you know i'm sitting from a
position of great privilege to be able
to pontificate about what i hope i could
do for things for people that come 200
years from now but nonetheless more and
more people can do that humanity's never
been in a better state quantifiably to
be able to start to think about these
intergenerational responsibilities
yeah this is a interesting balance
because like it seems that
if you let the ego flare up a little bit
that's good for productivity yeah like
saying i can somehow achieve immortality
if what i do is going to be pretty good
right but then
that's actually being kind of dishonest
with yourself because it won't
in the long arc of history won't matter
right in terms of your own ego but it
will have
a small piece to play in a larger puzzle
and help
people many generations from now
and that they said there are all these
people who were looking after me before
i was ever born i think um
it's because it's a bit of just uh even
just know what if when you go to a
campsite there's a camping rule that you
always leave the campsite better than
you found it so
if if the fire pit was somewhat damaged
and you got there you fix it if there
was no wood you leave a few bits of logs
for the next person who comes and this
ethos is something that uh just picked
up from camping and so i think if we did
that as people the world would be a
better place and the world coming ahead
would also be
that said with these entropy glasses
how can you
see through the fog 500 years is a long
time first of all why 500 years
most people this is so refreshing
because most
colleagues and friends i talk to are
don't have the guts
to think even like 10 years out
they started doing wishy-washy kind of
statements about well you don't know but
it's so refreshing to say all right i
know there's so many trajectories that
this world can take but i'm going to
pick a few and and think through them
and think what it's the well it's the
quote right plans are useless but
planning is assessed
so what why 500 years so 500 was a
little bit of what i felt like i could
see clearly through the entropy goggles
i feel like i can't i can't just the
contradiction in terms yeah right right
right i can see
i mean for example if you said uh chris
what's going to happen in a million
years well i'll start to describe
you know what happens to the you know
the moon will be farther away because it
moves several inches away every year and
so then eventually you can't have a full
lunar eclipse after a while i think
about structures of the continents will
change and things will move i could
describe some things but it starts to
become so
vague it's just not a useful exercise i
think it's too far out if it's too soon
that's not that much different from what
people just do with the news and say i
think this is what the economy might
look like over the next year or two
years economists are notoriously not
held accountable when they have really
bad predictions you can make really
awful predictions no one seems to care
you can just make another one next week
so
too short is i think not uh necessarily
as helpful but 500 i actually when i was
first working on the book and thinking
about type i thought well do i do a
thousand or two i kept thinking about
the main idea was if i were to pick this
up 500 years from now what would it look
like i changed the number if i pick up a
thousand years from now or a hundred
and i kept trying to think of
what are some time frames where really
large-scale changes have happened and so
in some sense you could argue that
humans been mostly the same for about
three or four thousand years and the
best example is you looked at some of
the homer's poems or the greek tragedies
uh and oedipus for example like humans
are really almost identic we're still
petty and people you know have affairs
and people do things they shouldn't and
people it's it's just saying that all
those things like it's bad
it's just me you're like you read that
it's astounding and in some sense
soothing that the greek tragedies of 2
300 years ago
are very relatable to what happens in
like in every high school right so like
you know people that's why you read them
in high school like oh that's really a
clear part of the human condition so in
that sense some things are really
permanent but i want to think of
a few reasons i chose 500 is that it's a
time frame where i could foresee
clear development of some biotechnology
that will get us to a new place
including missions to mars that are
planned that will be there and that we'd
start to have settlements there on the
moon and mars
and i could see also that by that time i
think we would have enough knowledge of
biology and technology and space
medicine
to start to prepare for an interstellar
mission to actually send people on a
craft that would have what's called a
generation ship
people live and die on the same
spacecraft on their way towards a
destination but i think we need that
much time to actually perfect the
technology and to learn enough about
physiology to be able to make it for
that distance
and
the book is kind of focused on the human
story
this is a specific slice of the possible
futures yes
there could be sort of ai systems it
could be other technologies that kind of
build up the world so much of the world
might be lived in virtual reality so
you're not touching any of that you're
sticking to biology we're not
you're you're touching a little bit but
focused on what
the cells that make up the human body
how do they change
how do we design technologies to repair
them and how do we
protect them and
as they travel out into the cosmos
absolutely and it's something that is
part of the duty if your duty is to keep
life safe you have to consider all means
to do so
and and engineering life to save itself
is definitely on that list
and you know i think we can
imagine
in that time frame 500 years
that we would you know there there
there will be ai that it's continually
advancing and i actually say that i'm
matter agnostic towards cognition so if
your matter is carbon atoms and cells
and tissues and you have cognition bravo
good for you if you're if you're silicon
based and you're in chips and you're an
ai that's all virtual but we reached a
state of you know well beyond the
touring test and really clearly
intelligent
congratulations to you too so i feel
like this sense of duty is is
applicable regardless of what the state
of matter your cognition is based in so
i would imagine that ai platforms
that are really intelligent might also
get a sense of this duty